Boo,
when do you think that this flying taxi will carry paying passengers?
Five years,
10 years beyond?
Well,
if you ask its maker helicopter,
it could be way sooner.
This is happening.
Now,
next year we fly.
Yep,
the startup says they plan to ferry passengers during the Paris 2024 Olympic Games
using their velocity aircraft.
So does this mean that commercial air taxis are finally here or will they disappear as
quickly as they arrive?
Let's find out.
Ok.
So if you hadn't heard that this thing was taking off,
then,
well,
you weren't alone when velocity flew here at the air show.
It was so quiet.
Some people didn't realize it was airborne,
you will see it but you will not hear it.
I think a lot of people missed it yesterday because they didn't hear our vehicle.
That's helicopter,
Ceo Dirk Hooker speaking at the announcement of the routes that the company intends to fly.
We will start with five aircraft.
We will fly every vehicle two flights per hour times five.
So it brings us to 80 to 100 flights a day.
The idea is to use these electric vertical take off and landing aircraft or toll to
connect five popular hubs around Paris during the games,
like airports to other airports or train station.
If they get airborne,
they might not be alone as fellow toll manufacturer,
auto flight have also announced that they intend to operate during the Paris Olympics.
So does this mean that you and your friends will be whizzing from sport to sport during next
year's games?
Well,
you might have to go one at a time as the aircraft only holds one passenger.
We would love to go directly to 4567 seater.
But we also have to be realistic on the speed of the development of battery technology.
Then there's how much each flight would cost,
which seems to be a work in progress.
How much is it going to cost the last one?
I cannot answer you because we didn't agree with our partners yet.
We are still in discussion ops told me that they are eventually aiming for tickets to cost 3 to
€4 per passenger per kilometer.
But they said to me that that was very aspirational and would require an aircraft that could carry more
passengers for.
Now,
they plan on offering subsidized tickets.
If you combine the potentially high ticket price with the single seat occupancy and
the fact that there will only be a couple of these things flying each hour,
then it means that helicopters flights during the Olympic Games could be less of an
efficient commuter route and more of a niche tourist experience for those at the
Games.
Can we replace a bus?
Can we replace a metro system?
No,
it's not even the attention we want to add another option.
And this is all if the company gets to Paris by the Olympic Games at all,
as their flights will be on the condition that their aircraft receives certification in time.
And that's a big if we said we plan and we aim for,
we strive for it because I cannot guarantee that we are ready ready because we are having a
very,
very challenging certification time plan.
So does that mean that Volta is more of a tourist experience than a bona
fide air taxi for now?
Maybe?
But that doesn't mean it always will be see there are a lot of toll startups trying to
get their aircraft off the ground and they're all going to have to start somewhere.
United has said it's working with Embers Eve to bring its air taxi to San Francisco and to
start up Archer has said it hopes to be operating during the Olympic Games in
2028.
And even if Voop doesn't make the Paris Olympic Games,
Dirk told me that he hopes the company will still be flying long after the games have departed,
we need to see how the public reacts,
but overall now we want to go 24 months and beyond.
So next time you're in Paris,
make sure to look up.
There could be a very quiet taxi with one passenger making its way through the
skies.